sorry auntie's husband is dead his body
was swallowed by the ground there will
be no funeral a mass grave will be his
final resting place so sorry aunty has
come to this lonely hillside to say
goodbye the risk of disease means her
wish cannot be granted
instead he must lie here with hundreds
of others killed in the earthquake and
tsunami it's time for Suri aunty sit
bury her husband she's determined to
accompany him to the end
the final prayer he's gone she brings us
back to Porto beau the place that used
to be her home where the village once
stood is now a muddy waste meant so the
house here and all houses here
hundreds of people the earthquake turned
this solid ground to liquid mud
a whole community possibly thousands of
people disappeared in Tana transitivity
by the lumpur Lhari sumo cooler already
selamatkan we are bombarded Chavo jr.
pteridophyta two lumbar palpable Terada
the military still searched this Riven
land they know there are no survivors
this is a recovery mission not a rescue
Suri auntie's pain is shared by hundreds
of others whole families were lost here
and some may never be found
made a widow by Nature sorry aunty now
grieves the home and the husband she's
lost
Siobhan Robbins Sky News potato in
Indonesia